bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france à leur
première question que pensez vous de ce
nouveau format du sommet afrique france
est ce que c'est un véritable progrès ou
une stratégie de communication de la
part d' emmanuel macron selon vous
bonjour madame aujourd'hui il faut dire
que c'est si l'innovation car c'est une
opportunité aujourd'hui à la jeunesse
africaine en dehors du monde politique
car ça c'était si vie des jeunes
entrepreneurs
artistes ou des sportifs qui seront
présents à ce sommet afrique-france qui
pourront s'exprimer directement avec le
précédent contrairement au passé où
c'était juste des sommet afrique france
avec des dirigeants des pays je pense
que c'est
initiative fait par le président macron
affaire d'être en contact directement
avec cette jeunesse qui est l'avenir de
l'afrique
la jeunesse africaine dont qui est au
coeur de ce sommet échanger avec elle
pour mieux comprendre peut-être les
problèmes qu'elle traverse et les enjeux
qui sont importants aujourd'hui sur
continent africain
effectivement aujourd'hui vous savez
lorsque vous rencontrez les dirigeants
de différents pays il ya certaines
choses qui ne pourront pas être dit
ouvertement car c'est tout est contrôlé
à la diplomatie à le rester il n'y a pas
le bien peu des tabous ya des mots qui
pourra pas sortir or que cette jeunesse
de sa réaction et de son expérience sur
le terrain parce que c'est eux qui sont
au day to day ou chaque jour
en face les réalités de l'afrique pour
en donner une manière de brut ce qui se
passe réellement en afrique avec ses
avantages et ses inconvénients et les
inconvénients pour être une opportunité
pour la france afin d'améliorer le
quotidien des africains pour développer
l'afrique rénover les relations avec
l'afrique c'est ce que souhaite
justement emmanuel macron mais on
n'avait que ces derniers temps il y
avait de l'eau dans le gaz des tensions
notamment avec certains pays le mali
aussi l'algérie
on sait il n'y aura pas de chefs d'état
présents à montpellier mais est ce que
cela peut quand même apaiser les
tensions sur le plan diplomatique où
elle a ses échanges avec la société
civile
sur le plan diplomatique
ça dépendra bien sûr de la communication
et de la proche de la politique
africaine de la france car aujourd'hui
nous sommes plus à l'époque que foccart
aussi le pré carré où c'est qu'avec les
dirigeants mais aujourd'hui je pense que
la france a une opportunité avec serré
pâte avec les expos rats afin de venir
renouveler une nouvelle diplomatie pour
la politique africaine afin de
développer ce partenariat 8 nuits que je
dirais car aujourd'hui vous savez nous
sommes dans
une nouvelle ère où nous avons internet
que tout le monde peut avoir la
formation au même instant et c'est la
même période aujourd'hui je pense que la
politique française pourrait profiter de
ses atouts et sa diversité car il faut
savoir une chose c'est que il ya
beaucoup d'espoir qui étudiants qui
veulent faire leurs études en france et
qui peuvent être aussi des personnes qui
pourront accompagner la france a
développé cette nouvelle politique aussi
bien aussi leur est pas qu aujourd'hui
par exemple comme moi présentement qui
suis retourné en rdc mon pays d'origine
afin de m'y installer alors vous êtes à
montpellier vous allez participer vous
même à ces échanges à ce sommet afrique
france en tant que jeune entrepreneur
qu'est ce que vous attendez justement de
la part du président emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour compagne mans
spécialement
fini au niveau des finances parce que
pendant plusieurs années la france a
fait accompagner financièrement
l'afrique on n'a pas vu de résultats
aujourd'hui une relation qui doivent
partager le savoir car c'est la seule
chose qui pourrait acquérir et
développer l'afrique et surtout la chose
d'une manière macro pour faire très
simple c'est que l'afrique a besoin
aujourd'hui de créer une classe moyenne
c'est le classement il peut être créés
par des valeurs ajoutées par exemple sur
leurs produits les matières premières
qui sont extraits en afrique les
minerais l'agriculture ou autre
ne pas le rendre en produits finis mais
au moins on peut lui ce produit semi
fini par avoir une petite plus value une
plus value avant l'exportation car
aujourd'hui il faut savoir une chose
l'afrique doit se développer
c'est un marché
qui a besoin de savoir
en plus du financement
vous êtes originaire du congo est ce que
on peut dire aujourd'hui que finalement
toute la jeunesse du continent africains
aspirent justement vous même ou même
demande ou même attente
d'une manière générale vous savez on
affecte souvent comme on dit on donne
pas du poids sans un t shirt on apprend
à pêcher et c'est ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous devons avoir les
connaissances le savoir si nous prenons
l'exemple avec la chine aujourd'hui
lorsqu'elle traite à marcher avec eux la
france et demande non seulement elle
acquiert par exemple des boeing ou
airbus mais demandent aussi le partage
de savoirs c'est ce qui peut se passer
aujourd'hui comment expliquer
qu'aujourd'hui en afrique par exemple en
rdc mon pays où nous avons du cuivre du
cobalt mais nous n'avons pas des câbles
électriques pour transporter l'énergie
parce que nous n'avons pas le savoir et
aujourd'hui je pense que cette jeunesse
là par exemple par le biais de
l'ambassade de france en rdc qui a
sponsorisé
une start up qui est dans le numérique
afin de former des jeunes qui ont
aujourd'hui leur première promotion a
tous pu avoir un travail et c'est ça qui
est le plus important c'est le savoir
merci beaucoup en tout cas john logan
nkoa et d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
économie entrepreneurs au congo